hey guys it's Jonah here I love a good
bowl of soup there are so comforting
nourishing and they are great to be
eaten all year round the good thing is
you don't have to be a good cook to whip
up a really tasty bowl of soup whenever
we think of our soup we always think
about a hearty warm bowl of soup
I do love my warm soups but I also love
chilled soups these chilled soups are
flavorful light refreshing and the best
part is you don't have to cook them so
they are extremely quick and easy to put
together and the varieties are endless
you can simply mix and match any
vegetables of your choice so I'm going
to share with you four of my favorite
chilled soups each recipe makes four
servings these recipes are very easily
adaptable to suit your diet whether
you're a vegan or vegetarian and because
they are chilled I like to make them
ahead happen for breakfast or you can
take them out to school or work for
lunch so let's start by making the
chilled mint cucumber yogurt soup in a
blender I'm going to add four cups of
chopped up cucumber for the creamy
texture I'm going to add one and a half
cup of yogurt half a cup of fresh mint
leaves one garlic clove minced two
tablespoons of freshly squeezed lemon
juice don't forget to also add in some
healthy fats so about two tablespoons of
extra virgin olive oil salt and pepper
to taste and finally about half a cup of
cold water let's blend it up
so this soup is ready to be eaten or you
can chill in the fridge for at least two
hours or overnight each serving has
about 100 and 13.5 calories this soup
goes really well with grilled chicken
fish couscous rice or even none you've
got to try it the next soup recipe has a
very delicious nutty flavor chilled
chickpeas a sesame soup in a blender I'm
going to add 2 cans of chickpeas rinsed
and drained 2 tablespoons of sesame
seeds 1 garlic clove minced quarter
teaspoon of ground cumin 3 tablespoons
of freshly squeezed lemon juice 2
tablespoons of extra virgin olive oil
salt and pepper to taste
and one and a half to 2 cups of water
depending on how thick you like your
soup if you like the crunchy texture of
chickpeas then just pulse it very
quickly or blend it up until the mixture
is smooth this is my favorite soup to
have for breakfast it is extremely
filling very easy to digest and I'm
getting all the good nutrients in One
Bowl one something has about 238
calories it is the perfect bowl of
goodness to kickstart my day
it can also be served as a light lunch
with a side of bread or even salad if
you enjoy your spice then you'll love
the chilled spiced tomato soup in a
blender I'm going to add 3 cups of
chopped up Tomatoes quarter cup of diced
cucumber quarter cup of diced red onion
quarter cup of diced red bell pepper 1
garlic clove minced about 2 tablespoon
of balsamic vinegar 2 tablespoons of
extra virgin olive oil half a teaspoon
of cumin 1 teaspoon of cayenne pepper
for the extra kick salt and pepper to
taste and just about 1 cup of cold water
I love the spiciness sharpness and
intense flavor of this soup it really
wakes to the palate up each serving only
has 73 calories so I've also topped it
up with some chopped up cucumbers
tomatoes onion and also olives it is
great as a light starter so if you're
looking to lose weight this soup will
fill you up and help you to eat less
during your main meal and finally let's
make this green bowl of chilled avocado
spinach soup so in a blender I'm going
to add about four cups of fresh baby
spinach one ripe avocado two tablespoons
of fresh basil one garlic clove minced
cut a cup of yogurt two tablespoons of
freshly squeezed lemon juice one
teaspoon of smoked paprika salt and
pepper to taste and about 1 to 2 cups of
cold water well if you don't like to eat
your vegetables this soup is a great way
to add more greens into your diet it has
a very unique fresh flavor that is very
satisfying and healthy so each serving
has about 83 calories and all the green
goodness if you have never had chilled
soups try these recipes they are so
flavorful convenient and I just love how
they can be eaten right from the fridge
so make them ahead and they will keep
well for up to 3 days don't be afraid to
experiment with different flavors and do
read my description box below for more
ideas on the different ingredients you
can use make them try them and let me
know which is your favorite chilled soup
don't forget to also share your creation
with me on Facebook and Instagram and
tag me at the chewiness our official do
like this video share this recipe and
subscribe to my youtube channel for more
fun healthy and really easy recipes all
the best
you